all right this is like the most
ridiculous [ __ ] i've seen it like this
seems like a bit
oh yeah totally couldn't and bro the
blueness in his eyes
like daniel craig is he's so sad after
double 07.
[Laughter]
daniel craig stopped dieting and got
really sad
listen to this [ __ ] guys what do you
want
what are you looking for
i don't even know what to say what about
what i see on here
that doesn't mean i don't appreciate
your beauty because there's a lot of
very attractive
women on here do you understand that you
instill in men
and insecurity a confusion about how
they need to be towards you
i'm picturing that he doesn't realize
that all the girls on this app
are 15. like he has no clue
and there are plenty of beautiful
beautiful women
i trust me i see you every day on my
feet
[Laughter]
this is the best part of this video is
that random little captions
just have nothing to do with this video
come on the dms here
i can't respond to dms here bro bro
let the rest of this play oh my god bro
you're looking at a man who's been
married twice divorced twice
against his will both times loyal all
the time
became a multi-millionaire it didn't
matter
both women left me for different reasons
one because she just didn't feel like i
fulfilled her emotional needs
the other one because she had an affair
on me
in between all that three kids between
two different women
lost their dad without them
oh my god man oh my god
look it's [ __ ] up that he's been
divorced twice man and i
i believe that he was a loyal dude but
just the way this sets up man it's like
i can't
i can't not laugh oh it feels
it's just an absurd it's just an absurd
video that's what i mean it's like the
post on tick tock like like
just your like relationship history and
all this stuff and
asking women what they want on tick tock
it's like there's a wrong place for this
it's like
it's so much [ __ ] in 60 seconds yeah i
think you're looking
i think you're looking for the
relationship advice yeah subreddit
actually
dude no you're looking for a [ __ ]
therapist
jesus christ dude this first line
this very first line hold on let it go
what the [ __ ] give me the audio
can i ask you women a question can i ask
you women what do you want
what are you looking for imagine going
down your feed
renegade renegade
that the relation dude can i ask you
women a question
what do you want
i mean it definitely draws you in you're
like oh
uh the mute the music too is perfect
it's like [ __ ] spa music
it's like the [ __ ] that you're listening
to kicking a [ __ ] in a
hot tub yeah in a hotel spa
imagine you're getting like an actual
like full body massage and this is your
massage therapist and he's saying all
this [ __ ]
what are you looking for you're on your
stomach it leans in
to your ear what do you want i don't
even know what to say what about what i
see on here
that doesn't mean i don't appreciate
your beauty because there's a lot of
very attractive women on here
could you not talk about my back like
that do you understand that you instill
in men
and insecurity what a confusion about
well they need to be towards you
i mean i'm not trying to i'm just i'm a
guy
worse twice okay that's okay well that's
oh that's a bummer dude but i i mean i
didn't really multi millionaire come on
i didn't matter
what what well then why are you supposed
to either
one because she just didn't feel like i
forgot i love that he [ __ ] adds
he's a multi-millionaire became a
multi-millionaire it didn't matter
multi multi-millionaire
oh oh my god divorced
twice became a multi-millionaire still
didn't matter
do you have to grab my head so hard when
you when you say all this like it's
really
painful
oh my god i'm hey man i'm a guy
i'm a guy i'm a guy you're not you don't
hear me i'm a guy
i'm not that doesn't matter
what do you want
he says all that then rolls you over and
sees your nub and he's like oh
oh i'm sorry
oh my god dude saying
saying you're a multi-millionaire in
this in in the middle of
this like pool of sadness is so crazy
like he's like crying
he's admitting to the world that his
first wife
left him for no reason and his second
wife cheated on him
this is batman dude yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god dude jesus bro
this dude's hurt man he's hurt tick-tock
is not
healthy oh man i feel so bad for him
dude
like tick-tock is the last place this
guy should be you know i could i can
only imagine what these comments are
oh i have to log in to see them uh wait
send them
send to me hold on or no let me know oh
wait wait wait wait wait wait we got it
okay also weird way of saying that she
had an affair on me
instead of [ __ ] on me have an affair on
me yeah have an affair on me
have an affair on me
you